à
deux pas du village le petit port de
l'ayrolle est surnommé le bout du monde
et sur les quais
ce sont les jeunes qui prennent la
relève
la pression commence à monter
le mal ce soir
à la place des filets benjamin baisse
charge des roseaux
[Musique]
ce ne sont pas les gestes habituels pour
un pêcheur mais c'est pourtant bien le
rituel de la fin de l'été
de grosses responsabilités pèsent sur
les épaules de ce jeune homme de 29 ans
il est responsable avec une poignée de
volontaires
du barrage de l'ayrolle
une étendue d'eau poissonneuse qui
communique avec la mer
alors au début c'est bingo c'est
chouette ou les crèches ou
les hommes sa ligne sur une borne à
terre puis se positionnent autour d'un
rectangle
en train de régler le cadre qui est déjà
préparé donc y aura une côté pour à 20
mètres et l'autre 40 il ne faut qu'on a
trouvé le bon côté de chacun c'est parti
une fois par an les pêcheurs kadri la
mer sur près de 3 km de longueur
il progresse ensemble des places leur
rectangle de cordes et à l'aide de
roseaux des limites des parcelles
parfaitement identiques
[Applaudissements]
ils devront partager les eaux avant ce
soir
la précision du tracé est déterminante
il faut respecter les alignements
recompter les roseaux bien en place
denis le père de benjamin
participent à ce travail collectif
depuis 40 ans
voilà c'est un plan d'alignement je
pense quand même tempo trop
faut pas faire d'erreur de mettre un
postale plus où on n'y pense pas moins
si on se plante et des fois il faut tout
recommencer chacun thériault beaucoup te
recommencer tous
les droits qui doit toujours par terre
c'est un partage et des gens qui doit
être équitable pour tous les pêcheurs
n'a pas une qui doit avoir plus que
l'autre on travaille en communauté on
est tous ensemble donc on se doit tous
être égaux
et avec la fatigue on se chamaille un
peu on se prend le bec cela aussi fait
partie du jeu
écoutez je ne pouvais pas monter de 10
mètres de course 6 est attendu c'est pas
moi commenté il faut que l'huile dessein
de dieu
vous a vu vous êtes beaucoup barré par
rapport à l'an passé
en fin d'après-midi les alignements de
roseaux devant la mer traces de lignes
parallèles
à l'intérieur on y installera des postes
de pêche
fils et lui pièges à poissons une fois
les temps paraît le dispositif va leur
assurer une source de revenus pendant
quatre mois
nous vendre tout le poisson est rentrée
depuis le mois de février mars et vénus
à bien se nourrir dans les étangs des
qui sent les eaux de mer et ce qui sera
fait rafraîchissant qui seul le mauvais
temps ils préfèrent partir regagner le
les formes les grands fonds comme les
barrages servent à maintenir une partie
du poisson
empêcher qu'on pêche une petite partie
en attendant de commencer le travail à
la mi septembre
les pêcheurs doivent se répartir
119 parcelles
autant de postes de pêche au rendement
bien différents selon les courants la
profondeur la nature des fonds marins
alors pour éviter tout favoritisme
c'est un tirage au sort qui va décider
de la répartition des postes
présent
heroes thivet du liban à damas le tirage
au sort une règle fondamentale de la
prud'homie des pêcheurs de gruissan une
institution puissante née au lendemain
de la révolution
dans ses registres et consignés toute la
vie des pêcheurs
le partage des territoires de pêche
les plaintes les procès verbaux de
conflits de sanction ou encore l'état de
la ressource et le détail des espèces de
poissons
[Musique]
22 promettre chaque chose chaque section
aujourd'hui les prud'hommes sont élus
pour trois ans par leurs pairs
issus de cette longue histoire benjamin
est le plus jeune élu de la prud'homie
de gruissan
j'ai été prudent mais j'aime bien 2018
c'est quand même pour moi très important
de défendre la vie de tous les pêcheurs
de faire que tout le monde se sente bien
que tout le monde ne soient égaux que la
prud'homie fonctionne ça fait partie de
la culture des pêcheurs de gruissan donc
c'est très important pour moi d'être
prud'hommes j'ai vu mon papa est pour
moi c'était fêter la suite à prendre
d'être prudent on commence
[Musique]
la distribution des lots a toujours lieu
le soir du barrage
au 1er louis marc
m
ad le pas de leurs rivales et là
dans cette pièce tout le monde est au
courant
papa il y à beaucoup plus de mauvais
poste que de bons à distribuer
ayrault
mais chacun croit en sa bonne étoile
quitte à brûler quelques cierges
mise en boîte de rigueur dans cette
communauté qui se connaît par coeur et
si cela permet d'effacer les tensions
on sait être si bon joueur patricia a eu
la main heureuse des noix et benjamin
alors
pas de pitié pour les prud'hommes
benjamin est un pêcheur comme les autres
l'an dernier j'ai déjà été gâté et cette
année aussi donc pourvu que ça continue
moi mon tirage les moyens ni bon ni
mauvais loin de bonne musique dans ma
carrière fait moi ça fait
26 ans que je fais la pêche j'ai déjà eu
tous les bons postes au moins trois fois
chacun c'est pas la peine
ce soir pas une voix ne contestera le
tirage au sort
respect et discipline
deux règles d'or de la communauté des
pêcheurs de gros isme
[Musique]
la prud'homie rythment la vie des
pêcheurs
elle est devenue une alliée forte pour
affronter les défis de demain et ça
benjamin l'a bien compris
j'ai essayé d'autres choses dans ma
sonnerie d'ombré mais le sua qui
m'accrochent vraiment l'unique et
c'était si là je n'arrivais pas à penser
autre chose ou à faire autre chose comme
le dirait je veux faire l'attachement
au bout du monde l'heure bleue
appartient aux gens de mer
les sérums bateau c'est normal petit
j'étais là mais copé préféré la plage
mon nom c'était mon père empêcher les
premières can mes amis sont comme été
avec un roseau ge d'équité 1 pc des
moments qui sont marqués dans ma vie que
maintenant je fais seule et que j'arrive
toujours pas à prendre conscience et
je me dire j'ai réussi à faire ce que je
voulais je vis de ma passion
où
une passion intacte nourri de ces
instants fébrile au lever du jour mais
sur les temps de son enfance
benjamin c'est que la donne a beaucoup
changé
sait jamais ce qu'on a le maté des
filets
ce petit quelque chose et qui fait qu'on
aime ce métier le jour je l'aurai plus
elle continuera
ce matin le jeune pêcheur traque mulet
loups dorades
je tape pour en faire rapport si
l'habitude que j'ai pris que j'arrive je
fais ça
allait
le travail a été calé la veille au fond
de l'eau pas tout à fait par hasard sur
cette étendue lagunaire de 1300 hectares
alors que lui réservent leur doré il y à
trois cents mètres à remonter
la première se fait en
cdi et comme on dit
arriva
devant le poisson mais se prend au lever
du jour
nouraï de mai 45 enfin 354 5 g facile un
beau morceau
le premier d'une longue série peut-être
hop une seconde
sur les rôles gérer la ressource est
devenu une priorité absolue
au sein de la prud'homie benjamins à
consolider des pratiques en augmentant
la mailles des filets par exemple la
pêche est plus sélective
un premier on pense à la ressource parce
que pêcher pour pêcher c'est pas le but
des chiffres pour en vivre des années ça
c'est au moins le bureau
[Musique]
pour la chose tout le petit poisson amer
pour qu'ils puissent granier revenir
sains et l'après cd conduite
éco-responsable connaissez de se
protéger aussi pour notre avenir à tous
les pêcheurs
on a vu que depuis quelques années
nicolas rochette on a de plus en plus de
perdre à l'état voilà qui est les
publics sont pêchés deux kilos et demi
c'est mdd délai si c'est rare mais c'est
quand même de gros poissons en un peu
plus de poissons de 4,5 5,5 g
weight et de la gestion
travailler tout en gardant une éthique
l'exemple de ces pêcheurs petits métiers
brille au soleil de l'ayrolle
[Musique]
lorsque la chaleur accable les flots de
la lagune père et fils se retrouvent
pour une pêche en duo
ici c'est le paradis de l'anguille que
l'on capture avec une cape et chad un
ingénieux montage de filet et de nass
amarré au fond de l'eau la communauté
des pêcheurs s'est elle même fixées
règles et interdiction alors là ça m de
paradis arrêtons appel à un guide utile
à taper dessus elle peut pas se prendre
et je suis d'un côté ou d'un autre ou
après un peu ça retourner aussi mais
c'est à chaque extrémité après un piège
est inoccupée chardin
et de la toute petite maya
est fait pour pas que le passage
justement le petit passe aussi près nez
et que nous on verrait pas et qui après
moeurs le but est justement juste qui
suivent pour se prendre rentrer dans le
coeur
et se prendrait restait alors que une
fois qu'il est dans la panade il est
vivant il bouge a pas de problème et
comment bien tous les deux trois jours
régulièrement visités et le poisson ne
possédant pas de taille ne souffre pas
comparer ma au travail
parade hier pente and cap et chad
l'ensemble vue duo dessine une flèche
bien connue des étangs de méditerranée
les poissons vivant glisse sans stress
jusqu'à la pointe
[Musique]
elles auront beau se tortiller les
anguilles se constitue prisonnière et se
retrouve maintenant en compagnie de
quelques crabe inoffensif
[Musique]
ah ouais ouais ouais
ça c'est beau
c'est de la bellongue il a imputé sur le
joli même aujourd'hui parce qu'avais la
vie lâche alors les pêches noir mason
toujours plus jolis les uns guide
chaque pêcheur a droit à six filets pas
un de plus sous peine d'amendé de la
prud'homie qui sur ce point est plus
stricte que le cadre européen
et un de nous mêmes on voit qu'à cause
de la chaleur languide commencent à
souffrir et tout ça de nous mêmes en
tant que pêcheur et les prud'hommes
décideront de lever les filets et je
n'ai pu l'empêcher ça je trouve ça et
vous avez vous écouté oui parce que je
pense que les pêcheurs sont aussi
dépendants de l'anguille si on peut
payer toutes langues et la pêcher pour
la tuer même pas pouvoir la vendre je
pense que ça ne sert à rien c'est du
gâchis
il est conscient il j'ai une bonne
séquence est là quoi on n'est pas là
pour tricher quand ça va pas pour le
dire en défendant le promis on
s'engueulait mais c'est en réunion
depuis la première heure une bonne
connaissance été remis non mais ça seul
à penser ça la prud'homie quoi c'est
pouvoir se dire les choses en face à
quel ça pète ça pète mais après c'est
terminé quoi ce qu'on a dit on ne lit à
la prud'homie passer des fois on a les
coréens tôt pêcheurs m a pris la place m
ça fait partie du travail est aussi quoi
mais après on a le respect d'autrui quoi
elle c'est fini c'est fini on n'en parle
plus
ce n'est pas tous les jours comme ça
mais disons le tout net aujourd'hui la
pêche est excellente sur le retour père
et fils active le réseau
web on arrive à prendre d'ici
minutes max
le mareyeur est déjà sur place il faut
aller vite car l'anguille est un poisson
fragile
vivante elle est vendue entre 4 et 8
euros le kilo
et pendant six mois de l'année elle fait
vivre les pêcheurs de l'ayrolle
signatures
contre 133 kg du sénat cette malle l'a7
direction sète d'aller dans les bassins
est après ça va à l'exportation en
espagne et au portugal
ça c'est pour le circuit classique
mais benjamin a choisi la modernité il
ira là où sont les attentes en circuit
court
à peine 16 km direction l'une des
meilleures tables de la région
[Musique]
c'est même du pain béni pour le jeune
chef laurent chabbert amateurs de
produits régionaux et de saison
là je vais lever l'anguille
d'alinghi de benjamin on a de la chance
on est là belpech
des anguilles cela correspond bien
grosse comme ça je les mettre sous vide
et de lecture en fête à la vapeur entre
10 et 12 minutes environ
on va rajouter les carottes du potager
du gras de porc un peu champignons une
bonne chose rouge bien réduite à ses
côtés
et voilà le travail
passer de mains d'experts à main de
maître
en guise de l'étang de l'ayrolle en
croustillons d'ail des ours déclinaison
à autour de la jeune carottes et son jus
de match relate
[Musique]
gruissan me gêne
glorifié en son temps par charles trenet
gruissan et ses habitants s'apprêtent à
chaviré ce week end
fin juin la ville fusionne avec sa
communauté de pêcheurs
le 29 on célèbre la saint pierre et ça
commence la veille par une grande
sardinade dans la cour de la prud'homie
chaque année il ya un engouement énorme
pour cet été pierre on le verra demain
et un monde fou qui viennent pour
célébrer crié pourquoi que marraine
décède pour koné du poisson et qu'il
était ratée un engouement qui prennent
tous gruissan et tu as fait plaisir à
voir parce que pour une fois le pêcheur
et
ce soir le pêcheur invite le village à
sa table et demain le village lui rendra
hommage
c'est un attachement viscéral
inter générationnelle
au revoir aux motos les jeunes des
petits fils de famille de pêcheurs que
chaque année qui leur tiennent vraiment
à coeur est bien de donner cours
bénévolement et c'est quelque chose que
pour moi émouvant gamin qui me tient à
coeur et qui fait plaisir que quand même
en 5e et je ne vienne avec nous lors ça
leur plaît je dis peut-être après nous
il y aura une autre génération se
connaissent tâches qu'on espère vous pas
que la prud'homie c'est fini c'est
[Musique]
pour la première fois de l'année la
chambre de saint-pierre est ouverte
à cette ancienne figure de proue
repêchés en mer par des marins
gruissanais on peut désormais
murmuraient des prières des voeux vous
confesser dépêché une ferveur singulière
tombe sur la ville
10h du matin rue de la prud'homie
l'heure des discours les officiels de la
région sont présents en uniforme des
préoccuper de l'étang de campignol jean
jacques sébastien benjamins ont revêtu
la robe et la toque des prud'hommes
et au même moment dans l'église
non pas encore
[Musique]
j miro
fabrice n'est pas un fada non le chef de
musique répète ses gammes car dans moins
d'une heure les pêcheurs vont
interpréter ici même le fameux scottish
[Musique]
c'est une danse qui à l'origine
viendrait de d'allemagne qui se ruinent
german paule ka qui sera arrivé dans les
années 1840 1850 à paris puis après
partie sur l'angleterre alors qui sait
peut-être là bas les écossais ou marin
écossais se serait peut-être qu apparaît
donc et puis bon c'est pour que la
raison est arrivé jusqu'ici
[Musique]
tout à l'heure l'église sera trop petite
pour accueillir tout le monde
10h45 st-pierre prend son premier bain
de foule
[Musique]
oh
aux premières mesures de la fanfare on
célèbre enfin le patron des pêcheurs à
tue tête avec ce champ que tous
connaissent et attendait depuis l'année
dernière
[Musique]
je
oh
mido famille dollars et dont c'est la
surface la seule femme issue récit mire
et puis regarde le public y présentent
leur façon de danser chacun a la sienne
qui est assez particulière certains ont
plus chaloupé que d'autres d'autres des
petits pas d'autres un peu plus rapide
[Musique]
comme prévu sous la baguette de fabrice
les travailleurs de la mer s'élance dans
une église pleine à craquer
[Musique]
on
au bout de l'allée il embrasse
l'ostensoir
puis au nord saint pierre et surtout
saluent leurs trois représentants
[Musique]
cette danse païenne restitue le pas des
marins en mer
et dans ces instants d'émotion intense
croyants ou pas chacun a sa vérité
l'impression qui connaît une bénédiction
au dessus de nous que notre bateau coule
pas que ainsi des chiffres qui nous
arrivent pas de malheur notre pied ne se
prenait pas dans un filet dans des jours
de mauvais temps voilà on est quand même
il ya ce petit rythme missionné par un
ami qu'on est la petite étoile au dessus
de la tête
[Musique]
et celui là poussent bien loin à la
symbolique de la chaloupe ceir aux vieux
briscards mystique
là c'est bien pensé servane tous et
spirituelle
en fait la bougie c'est la lumière qui
guident un peu la barque de la vie
le début que je la faisais j'étais
stressée je n'étais pas bien j'étais
attendu maintenant donc plus tôt mais là
je suis vraiment dans mon peu dans ma
bulle quoi jamais égal ce qui se passe
autour je le vois même personne c'est
pas je vends oui c'est vraiment que
j'avais une pression les gens à regarder
tous ces
[Musique]
héroïque le réveil gruissanais a joué
cette année 42 minutes sans interruption
le scottish gruissanais a encore
bouleversée l'assemblée
à la mémoire d'un parent d'un proche
certainement pas retenu leurs larmes est
certain aussi d'ailleurs
à l'idée que denis le pape à partir à la
retraite et danse peut-être pour la
dernière fois
[Musique]
on
ea n'a tellement fière de filmer son
mari benjamin et son pitchouns elie
sûrement un pêcheur celui là
dans quelques années
[Musique]